welcome back to CBS this morning this
broadcast is committed to finding out
why prices for many common items have
surged in recent years and today we look
at the rising cost of cars Americans are
paying about 38% more for a new car or
truck over the summer than they were
just 10 years ago and the average
transaction price for some popular
vehicles is up nearly 50 60 even 70
percent so how our driver is affording
it well as we found out many are not
right you can always count on the auto
industry oh yeah keep your heart
pounding you can be an explorer right
here on earth and your imagination race
it's the official truck
people but before you hurry on down to
your local lot consider our experience
here in Vineland New Jersey the typical
family takes home about $39,000 a year
after taxes we were curious what kind of
car or truck could we get on that income
so we checked in with CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger kind of our
in-house financial planner and she
recommended spending ten to fifteen
percent of that income monthly on a
vehicle that leaves us with about a $400
a month budget so let's see what we can
get Tony welcome
Ivan Nelson how you doing Tony at
family-owned Lewiston Ford the manager
whoo does not really believe this car
yeah it's a Super Bowl with a Ford
Explorer packed with technology these
are sonar sensors all sensors you see
the tire pressures are all set at 41 no
more putting the gauge on the tire and
measuring it right manually this
touchscreen is now standard its standard
on all models absolutely the car itself
has Wi-Fi as it has a modem we also saw
a powerful f150 lariat not only a
12-volt but has a 110 it's got its own
GPS own GPS there's even a button here
that adjusts the pedal right angle but
was any of it in our $400 budget your
monthly payment would be 853 853 all
right not even close
and that's life for a record number of
Americans these days the Big Three
automakers are retiring many family
sedans while rolling out souped-up SUVs
and trucks at premium rates that
families often can't afford without
taking on loans that are now larger and
longer than ever I know it sounds crazy
but I couldn't get rid of the screen and
just go back to the old cassette tape
and the Ivan did find us a simpler truck
closer to our budget but with a catch
look at that for 46 but 96 months how is
that eight years eight years those long
loans can create lower monthly payments
but it doesn't always mean you can
afford the car more and more vehicles
are ending up here at the repo lot last
year a record number of Americans fell
behind on their car payments more than
seven million people at least
90 days late okay and when that happens
people like CJ faceand get a call his
family sells repossessed vehicles at
auction in Delaware we asked if he's
seen more business tons tons of radios
yeah I would say it's probably doubled
if not triple Wow yeah why I think
mainly because there's people who are
going longer terms on cars are more
expensive you owe more on the car than
what it's worth
do you think that car manufacturers have
a role in this I think they do they have
priced cars out of a lot of people's
budgets
there's finance companies through these
manufacturers now to let people afford
these cars by stretching the loans out
to six seventeen years on a car blows my
mind we reached out to the three biggest
American automakers the fundamental
mystery to me is why there's a median
income a middle class income not get you
the average car anymore
manufacturers play a key role in setting
vehicle prices I mean I'll put it
bluntly art are you guys being greedy
but none would go on camera to discuss
pricing and we still needed a car so
welcome to Chevrolet sir we headed south
in search of a better deal down here in
Winter Haven Florida a typical family
income is about $35,000 a year after
taxes which means a responsible monthly
car payment might be about 350 dollars
thank you we zeroed in on a new Chevy
Impala this one does not have ventilated
seats no ventilated seats no but once
again our budget was shot can I get rid
of the halogen headlamps no he was open
no the infotainment system no in the end
the only car in stock that our
middle-class budget would comfortably
allow was the spark Chevrolet's smallest
fuses she's got the only one you have on
the lot I have two just like that one
there's they're twins but same color
same color what is that a Pinker in the
red it's a pig can we call it a red
we can't call it red but it's a pink
yeah we'll call it a red just a red yeah
[Laughter]
Chevy spark the official color on that
car by the way is raspberry somewhere
between red I want to thank those guys
at Lewiston forward and also Winterhaven
Chevrolet they tried to get me a good
deal ultimately this comes down to the
car manufacturers and in statements to
CBS here's what they said GM pointed to
a customer driven trend to larger
vehicles and said that household incomes
are up and interest rates are low so
they think that on a relative basis new
vehicles are actually a steal chevrolet
told us it's prices are based on what
the customer wants and feels they are
worth and ford declined to comment
overall now so they're saying the
customers want these bigger better
vehicles but I don't think the customer
wants 600 billion in new auto debt over
the past ten alone the Reds out over six
seven eight years now they can't have a
lot of interest that you you pay oh yeah
I remember when it used to be three to
four years and we thought that was a
long time eight years sign of the times
yeah so these they're there they're
prioritizing innovation and not
affordability and so a little part of
the American Dream is just floating away
now which will look good in that
rasberry car